Now one important detail we'll need to understand is how to get our image data
that our artists create into our game. For example, the image file name. Also
the width and height of the image, whether it's been rotated at all and various
other pieces of information we might need to know. Now to do this, we're going
to use JSON, which is a very lightweight data interchange format that's based on
JavaScript object syntax. Now, since it's based on JavaScript, it turns out that
it's really easy to use with JavaScript. Much easier than, say XML. Now, here's
an example of a JavaScript object, right here. Now, this is in JSON.
Technically.
It is the JavaScript object representation of JSON that has been passed in. The
difference between a JavaScript object and JSON is that JSON is simply a string
that we can then parse to create a java script object. And that's what we're
going to do.